[Music]
making retro-style toasters as this
british companies bread and butter while
some of its models are new designs in a
vintage style this one is authentically
retro in continuous production since the
1960s install the bread ejector next the
heating elements being a high-end
toaster the elements are sheets of pure
mica a mineral that's heat resistant up
to 1,800 degrees Fahrenheit they connect
them with electrically conductive copper
links they mount the switch that selects
the number of bread slices to toast then
they install a red neon light that
illuminates when you start the toaster
and turns off when the toast time has
elapsed the timer switch has a bell that
sounds when the toast time is up at
which point to switch cuts the current
to the elements they attach the dials
for the slice selector and timer
switches and connect their wires to the
main power cord then they place the
toaster compartment into the body and
screw on the toasters stainless steel
top the protective film now removed they
flip the toaster upside down and wire up
the elements they install the ejector
now positioning its spring against the
bread ejector when the bell rings
indicating your toast is ready
you move the knob to raise and retrieve
your slices a technician tests the
toaster thoroughly ensuring that all the
elements heat to the correct temperature
that only the selected slots heat up
that the timer is accurate and that the
bell rings when the selected time
elapses they install the removable crumb
tray then close up the bottom of the
toaster with a ventilated base plate
nylon feet elevate the toaster for
ventilation and to prevent the screws
attaching the base from scratching your
kitchen counter the style may be retro
but this 1960s design toaster was ahead
of its time with its energy-saving slice
selector feature that stops the toasters
empty slots from heating up
unnecessarily